et on sera dans ce club des territoires
aujourd'hui avec Arnaud Benedetti
bonjour rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire et Benjamin
Morel constitutionnaliste bonjour
Benjamin on va parler dans ce club des
territoires avec Quentin calmer
également et bien on parle non je ne
vous ai pas oublié quand on ne vous
inquiétez pas on va parler et bien de la
semaine d'Emmanuel Macron qui est revenu
sur le terrain à la rencontre des
Français tant bien que mal dans le bruit
des casseroles et bien il a essayé de
tourner la page de la réforme des
retraites on verra si c'est une
opération réussie et on s'intéressera
sur et bien on s'interrogera à la crise
démocratique que le pays connaît
actuellement puisqu'une majorité de
français estime que notre démocratie est
en mauvaise santé mais d'abord on va
voir l'actualité de nos élus locaux
et on va retrouver Christophe Rouillon
qui est maire socialiste de Coulaines
dans la Sarthe et également
vice-président de l'Association des
maires de France en charge de l'Europe
bonjour Christophe Rouillon
bonjour alors vous êtes en duplex avec
nous depuis la Pologne et vous revenez
et bien d'un sujet en Ukraine à
l'occasion du sommet internationale des
régions et des villes vous êtes rendu
dans des zones qui ont qui ont été
ravagées par cette guerre en Ukraine
quelle est la situation sur place et que
vous en dit et bien les élus locaux sur
place les vélos locaux que vous avez
rencontré
la situation est très tendue sur place
nous étions à Kiev et dans plusieurs
localités qui ont été frappés
dès le déclenchement de la guerre
il y a un climat qui est de tension avec
des alertes régulières d'attaque de
domicile donc voilà la population reste
mobilisée
les gens ne peuvent plus craignaient n'a
jamais été aussi forte dans sa
détermination à résister à l'envahisseur
russe voilà il y a deux situations
néanmoins il faut le préciser c'est la
situation dans le don-basse ou là il y
avait un moment encore une guerre de
terreur qui est exercée par par la
Russie et puis la situation dans le
reste du pays d'une situation de
d'incertitude de tension et de menaçant
alors que vous en dit les élus locaux
sur place quels sont leurs besoins à
court terme et à plus long terme
ils nous ont rappelé le combat qui
venait actuellement par l'Ukraine quel
combat pour bien entendu la défense de
leur liberté de la souveraineté mais
c'est un combat aussi pour toute
l'Europe parce que les objectifs de
Poutine des vitalités de la rappeler
hier en réunion en bilatérale se dépasse
simplement de s'emparer de l'Ukraine
c'est aussi d'aller plus loin demain qui
sera la future cible est-ce que ce sera
les états balles parce que ça la salande
est-ce que ce sera la Pologne voilà il y
a une vieille stratégie de développement
de l'Empire en poste soviétique de la
part de de la Russie sans aucun état
d'âme c'est-à-dire en frappant les
populations civiles on a vu à irpinnes
et à Bruxelles également les les
résultats de ces attaques qui sont des
attaques délibérées contre les immeubles
d'habitation
les infrastructures civiles il y a pas
d'objectif militaire il y en a eu bien
entendu mais là c'est vraiment une
volonté de terrorisme les populations et
ce que l'on a constaté c'est que la
stratégie d'esprit des populations
attaquer les infrastructures
d'électricité d'eau etc n'a pas payé
parce que l'Ukraine est toujours debout
vous avez également rencontré le
président ukrainien à Zelinski qu'elle
est qu'elle a été son message
un message très fort d'abord de
remerciements pour pour la France pour
engagement de notre pays en particulier
pour la livraison dame également un
message de remerciement des
collectivités locales françaises qui se
sont mobilisés d'abord pour accueillir
les réfugiés Ukrainiens les femmes les
enfants les personnes âgées et également
pour souvenir du du matériel je
comprendsais également le prix d'une
association des mains de France David
lister dans ce déplacement en plus de la
fonction de président du groupe
socialiste Comité des régions il a
remercié les collectivités locales de
rock et en particulier
locales françaises d'abord fournit des
générateurs du matériel qui est qui ont
permis de te dire pendant la période
d'hiver
du matériel pour tenir dans cette
période alors également un accueil des
réfugiés comment se passent et bien plus
d'un an après le début de la guerre
justement l'accueil des réfugiés dans
nos communes est-ce que il évolue est-ce
que les communes tiennent bon pour
accueillir ces réfugiés
je pense que ça se passe plutôt dans des
bonnes conditions nous avons accueilli
des familles ukrainiennes les enfants
sont scolarisés je pense qu'elle
souhaite revenir de leur pays le plus
tôt possible et d'ailleurs c'est là où
il y a aussi l'enjeu de la
reconstruction et nous étions aussi en
Ukraine pour pour préparer ce plan de
reconstruction d'ailleurs grande
surprise est positif que j'ai vu que
nous avons vu que sur le terrain en
particulier à bout de chat il
reconstruire des ponts il commence à
reconstruire les immeubles il faut
attendre bien entendu dans le combat que
la l'agression et l'attaque continue
mais voilà il y a cette volonté d'avoir
un plan de massif de reconstruction de
l'Ukraine de d'amélioration du lien
entre l'Europe et
l'Ukraine voilà ça va nécessiter à la
fois un appui technique des
collectivités locales pour ça qu'ils
souhaitent développer les partenariats
et puis aussi un engagement financier
important de l'Union européenne et de ce
point de vue là j'ai plaidé dans mon
intervention hier dans l'heure du sommet
après représente qui s'est tenu au
président de
guimersky pour qu'il y ait un grand
emprunt européen sur le modèle de celui
que nous avons eu pour le covid pour
financer les centaines de milliards
d'euros de dégâts et puis renforcer le
partenariat entre l'Ukraine et l'Union
européenne également faire intervenir
les entreprises européennes en
partenariat sur le territoire dernière
question vous le disiez Christophe
Rouillon soutient technique des
collectivités européennes pour la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine concrètement
comment ça va se passer c'est les
collectivités vont apporter de
l'ingénierie locale
exactement les collectivités locales
ukrainiennes de demande pas de temps
pour l'instant
des moyens financiers et d'ailleurs nous
serons très vigilants sur l'utilisation
des fonds la médecine était très claire
il faut plus de décentralisation en
Ukraine aussi des mesures très strictes
de surveillance pour lutter contre les
risques de corruption mais comme vous le
titre qu'il faut un appui technique pour
reconstruire les éductions d'eau les
systèmes d'électricité un appui
financier aussi pour être capable de
d'avoir des des plans de financement à
long terme qui se fassent en coût aussi
reporté pour les collectivités locales
ukrainiennes donc voilà il va y avoir un
vaste appel pour les collectivités
locales français n'est pas simplement
des produits là mais aussi les les
petites villes de France les villes
moyennes et pourquoi pas également les
villages pour qu'il y ait un soutien de
la part de nos techniciens de nos
ingénieurs de nos élus il y a un grand
travail en partenariat à effectuer tant
d'un point de vue politique également
d'appui à de construction d'une d'une
décentralisation du crâne et d'une bonne
gouvernance au plan local merci beaucoup
Christophe Rouillon d'être intervenu
dans cette émission en direct de Pologne
je rappelle que vous êtes maire
socialiste de Coulaines dans la Sarthe
et vice-président de l'Association des
maires de France en charge de l'Europe
merci à vous on va ouvrir et bien le
premier thème de débat de ce club des
territoires messieurs on va parler et
bien la semaine d'Emmanuel Macron qui a
essayé de revenir au contact des
Français après et bien la promulgation
de la réforme des retraites un contact
difficile avec le terrain le président
Emmanuel Macron était hier dans
l'Hérault pour parler rémunération des
enseignants une visite qui a encore été
un petit peu chahutée la journée est
racontée par Mathias Raes
deuxième déplacement consécutif même
ambiance à Ganges un bruit en comité
d'accueil attendait Emmanuel Macron
[Applaudissements]
après un concert de casserole la veille
en Alsace la préfecture de l'Hérault
décide d'interdire les dispositifs
sonores portatifs pas de quoi atteindre
la détermination des manifestants selon
le député la France insoumise du
département Sébastien Rome
pendant cette visite sur le thème de
l'éducation le chef de l'État en a
profité pour confirmer les augmentations
salariales pour les enseignants en plus
de cette augmentation du socle entre 100
et 230 euros par mois selon les moments
de la carrière il y aura justement
quelque chose qui sera fait en plus
c'est défini avec le chef
d'établissement sur une base totalement
volontaire et qui va permettre de payer
encore plus par mois ce qui permettra
des enseignants de toucher jusqu'à 500
euros par mois en plus des annonces
jugées hors-sol et irresponsables le
soir même par les organisations
syndicales du secteur de son côté le
président de la République l'assure il
continuera d'aller au contact dans les
prochains jours
sur le terrain d'Emmanuel Macron au
contact des Français il est plutôt
difficile que ce soit dans l'Hérault ou
dans l'Alsace finalement ce n'est pas
surprenant vu le contexte social non pas
même Emmanuel Macron dit je ne suis pas
surpris non la difficulté c'est que si
vous voulez en fait il veut imposer une
nouvelle lecture de la situation montrer
que il n'est pas bon guérisé à l'Elysée
que il peut se déplacer librement ce qui
est tout à fait normal pour un président
de la République dans le pays qu'il va
au contact et espérant que finalement
ces images qui sont des images
difficiles en effet pour lui il finit se
retourne dans sa faveur pour que on
reconnaisse que il a du cran qu'il est
courageux qu'il est audacieux que
finalement il est prêt à se confronter à
l'adversité y compris à l'adversité un
peu dur et rugueuse et il fait le pari
que sur la distance d'une certaine
manière l'opinion publique ou une partie
de l'opinion publique lui le créditera
de ce de ce de ce courage là en fait il
essaye de refaire d'une certaine manière
ce qu'il avait fait à l'issue de la
crise enfin au moment de la crise des
gilets jaunes mais il y a d'abord il y a
trois éléments fondamentaux qui sont
très différents entre 2018 et 2023
d'abord un point essentiel c'est qu'en
2018 il avait cédé il avait cédé sur le
fond au revendications des gilets jaunes
là il cède pas il est encore dans un
bras de fer avec les syndicats en tout
cas les syndicats sont toujours dans un
bras de fer avec lui le deuxième élément
c'est que en 2018 il avait un an de
mandat aujourd'hui on est à la 6e année
de
avec le deuxième mandat et donc vous
avez des traits j'allais dire presque
psycho-politique qui se sont quand même
fortement installés dans la perception
que l'opinion publique se fait des
manuels Macron c'est plus le même homme
d'une certaine manière il a aujourd'hui
disons plus la fraîcheur ou l'innocence
qui était la sienne même en 2018 malgré
des difficultés de l'affaire Benalla et
des gilets jaunes 3e élément c'est un
élément parlementaire c'est que en 2018
et il avait une majorité absolue
l'Assemblée nationale et que là il a une
majorité très relative en l'occurrence
voilà et là il est plus affaibli
politiquement ben finalement Emmanuel
Macron et bien il aime ce récit d'un
président qui vient au contact des
Français les affronter dans une crise
dans une crise sociale oui il faut lui
reconnaître une forme de courage
physique et c'est à dire que chaque fois
qu'il y a une crise il arrive au devant
des Français il essaye de rentrer en
dialogue ces méthodes de communication
qui est assez bien huilée mais qui
marche pas toujours c'est justement de
ce confronter à un français lambda et en
se confrontant en français lambda alors
qu'il peut être plus ou moins député un
militant l'arène parfois mais et bien il
y a une possibilité de le retourner et
si je retourne le français lambda et
bien potentiellement je retourne les
gens qui s'identifient à lui dans les
images télévisées donc ça cette méthode
là d'y arrive bien tout bêtement parce
que il est plutôt bonne orateur parce
qu'il sait justement convaincre etc et
ça peut bien fonctionner mais tout à
l'heure Arnaud parlait du grand débat
dans le grand débat ça pue bien
fonctionner à des moments en revanche
souvenez-vous de entre la crise Benalla
et la crise gilet jaune vous avez à
l'époque ce qu'on appelle la grande
déambulation mémorielle il va notamment
dans l'est de la France et il essaye de
retourner l'opinion on est en protocrice
des gilets jaunes et ça se retourne
contre il y a des petites phrases il y a
des moments de tension avec certains
Français et ils montrent que justement
il a pas de réponse à cette crise du
pouvoir d'achat là on a quelque chose
qui ressemble beaucoup plus à la
déambulation mémorielle qu'au grand
débat parce que en effet et bien les
réponses du président de la République
sont souvent hors-sol au vu des
préoccupations des Français parce que
comme la très bien dit Arnaud
aujourd'hui c'est non seulement un
président qui crispe dans l'opinion mais
qui également est en partie impotant
parce que pas de majorité parlementaire
parce que marche budgétaire limitée même
si quelques milliards ont été lâché hier
donc ce faisant il y a un risque que ces
images qui parient sur un élément qui
est l'élément phare la principale
ressource d'Emmanuel Macron c'est à dire
lui-même son charisme et bien finissent
par se retourner et par exacerbant
encore un peu plus les tensions contre
lui alors en 2018 il y avait le symbole
du gilet jaune maintenant il y a le
symbole de la casserole et d'ailleurs le
préfet hier a interdit les casseroles
autour de la visite d'Emmanuel Macron
Arnaud ça n'a l'air de rien mais est-ce
que c'est peut-être un nouveau symbole
de la contestation à vis-à-vis du
président
alors c'est très différent parce que si
vous voulez en 2018 les les
itinérances dans les grands débats
d'Emmanuel Macron ne donnaient pas
forcément lieu à des manifestations
comme les manifestations qu'on a connu
depuis
il y a 48 heures il était en Alsace et
hier dans dans l'Hérault si vous voulez
la situation est beaucoup plus me semble
et c'est le paradoxe d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus tendu qu'elle ne l'était même au
moment des gilets jaunes quoi qu'elle
était tordue au moment des gilets jaunes
mais pas un moment du grand débat au
moment des grands débats on était en
train avec malgré tout il y avait une
forme de décrue si vous voulez bon les
casseroles c'est symboliquement la
volonté des opposants les plus
déterminés à cette réforme de lui dire
non on ne vous écoute pas non on ne veut
pas vous entendre oui on va couvrir
votre voix parce que votre voix n'est
plus audible dans le moment que nous
traversons et une fine et finalement
cette symbolique des casseroles elle
vient d'une certaine manière totalement
j'allais dire vampiriser
un exercice de communication auquel il
est en train de se prêter puisque
l'exercice de communication vise à
montrer un président de la République en
action sur le terrain en mesure d'aller
répondre aux Français mais en même temps
qu'est-ce qu'on retient quand même de la
manière la plus forte en tout cas depuis
le début de la semaine ça peut changer
peut-être dans les semaines qui viennent
c'est quand même la symbolique des
casseroles donc de ce point de vue là
dans la bataille d'image que ce livre le
président de la République et les
opposants à la réforme je dirais en tout
cas en cette fin de semaine il y a
plutôt un avantage du côté des opposants
une bataille d'image notamment autour
des casseroles et Emmanuel Macron a eu
des petites phrases sur ce sujet il a
dit les casseroles ça sert à faire la
cuisine ça ne va pas faire avancer la
France est-ce que ces petites phrases
qu'on connaît bien chez Manuel Macron ça
peut se retourner contre lui bien sûr
que ça peut se retourner contre lui tout
bêtement parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
un moment de gravité pour beaucoup de
Français qui ont des problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez un moment qui est un moment de
tension et je dirais une relativisation
de ce moment-là une relativisation de la
contestation évidemment accroît le
sentiment que l'exécutif est déconnecté
à la fois de cette gravité et en même
temps et bien du sentiment que là il y a
vraiment un enjeu et que cet enjeu il
doit y répondre donc la légère ironique
est celle d'Emmanuel Macron est
fondamentalement contre-productif pour
lui par ailleurs et bien c'est simple
c'est casserole elle symbolise quelque
chose parce qu'en réalité comme je le
disais tout à l'heure la force
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de retourner son
auditoire la casserole c'est justement
le refus de communiquer et donc il est
face à un dilemme en termes de
communication qui est compliqué si vous
regardez hier il y a des côtés un peu
villages potamines quand il intervient à
certains moments et donc soit vous êtes
dans une communication totalement
éthérée vous avez un chef de l'État qui
semble évoluer dans un monde parallèle
en expliquant par ailleurs dans ses
propos que en fait la vraie France elle
est là ce qui est terrible parce qu'en
réalité la vraie France évidemment tout
le monde le sait notamment les gens qui
regardent elle n'est pas là soit vous
rentrez dans une logique est une logique
de confrontation avec des gens qui
refusent par définition par principe de
vous écouter et là vous neutralisez tout
ce qui était le logiciel de
communication macronien et qui avait
réussi jusqu'à présent alors dans la
stratégie d'Emmanuel Macron il y a le
retour sur sur le terrain et il y a le
fait de lancer la fameuse période des
100 jours le président de la République
veut relancer certains chantiers sur le
travail sur l'école sur la santé ça a
été dessiné dans son allocution de lundi
et regardez ce qu'en pense les Français
62% estiment que ce n'est pas la bonne
méthode c'est chantier déclinés sur une
période de 100 jours et 79 % estiment
que ce n'est pas réaliste d'avoir des
vrais résultats dans ces domaines donc
finalement et bien Arnaud Benetti on
voit que les Français ne sont pas
convaincus par cette manière de tourner
la page des retraites d'Emmanuel Macron
oui enfin ce sondage confirme de ce que
l'on sait déjà depuis un certain temps
est-ce que d'autres sondages avaient dit
c'est que les Français continuent à
soutenir d'abord la mobilisation contre
les retraites malgré la promulgation de
la loi par le l'exécutif et par le
Président de la République et ça c'est
un peu une vraie surprise d'ailleurs
parce qu'on aurait pu penser et c'était
le pari que faisait l'exécutif nous
disons bon finalement une fois que ça va
passer une fois que la procédure je veut
dire nominal sera enregistrée les
Français vont prendre acte et ça va
décroître l'arrêter c'est que ça ne
décroît pas aujourd'hui au niveau de
l'opinion publique donc ça c'est un
premier élément et c'est un premier
échec pour Emmanuel Macron ensuite sa
prise de parole en effet était une prise
de parole qui était une prise de parole
finalement répondant à un objet
politique de très basse intensité il
avait des objets politiques de plus
haute intensité pour essayer de sortir
de la crise il ne les utilise pas alors
sans parler de la dissolution sans
parler du référendum il pouvait
éventuellement procéder à un remaniement
un resserrement de son équipe
gouvernementale il ne l'a pas fait il
pouvait alors là
un peu plus éventuellement procéder à
changement de Première ministre il ne va
pas le faire plus de toute façon c'est
très difficile en effet de se séparer
d'une première ministre qui est quand
même a fait le job au niveau de la
réforme des retraites donc il utilise ce
qui lui reste qu'est-ce qui lui reste
bah il lui reste l'outil de
communication mais l'outil de
communication c'est finalement une arme
politique qui aujourd'hui est très
faible et qui concernant em Macron
commence à être un peu aujourd'hui érodé
parce que on connaît un peu la façon
dont il procède donc il arrive même pas
là de ce côté là sur le plan de la
communication a vraiment pour reprendre
une formule qu'il aime beaucoup se
réinventer Benjamin Morel on va parler
dans quelques instants et bien du
malaise démocratique qu'on connaît
actuellement mais d'abord un mot sur
cette stratégie des 100 jours et ses
différents chantiers dans différents
secteurs finalement ça ne marche pas
dans l'opinion publique l'opinion
publique et pas non plus idiote s'agit
noyé le poisson comment voulez-vous avec
les chantiers qui ont été lancés qui
sont quand même des chantiers
structuraux d'une campagne
présidentielle et qui tourne dans les
tiroirs depuis certains 2017 et bien
arrivé à tout changer en 100 jours quand
vous n'êtes pas capable de faire passer
le mot au Parlement evidemment c'est pas
évident vous pouvez rentrer en dialogue
mais la réalité c'est qu'il y a personne
qui veut dialoguer avec vous aujourd'hui
ou presque et donc ce faisant comment
est-ce que vous faites vous allez dire
que vous allez réformer par décret ben
oui évidemment vous allez pouvoir faire
des choses mais ça sera pas audible ce
sera pas visible donc aujourd'hui on a
un pouvoir qui est en grande partie
engoncé contraint et ce pouvoir engoncé
contraint lance des grands chantiers en
espérant que les perches soient
ramassées mais vous avez une opinion qui
ne veut pas changer de séquence vous
avez une opinion qui a compris qu'il y
avait malgré tout une fragilité une
contrainte du pouvoir et donc vous avez
une opinion qui n'est pas dupe alors
après cette promulgation de la réforme
des retraites et bien il y a aussi un
sentiment de malaise de crise
démocratique un plus une grande majorité
de français estime que notre démocratie
aujourd'hui n'est pas en bonne santé et
Quentin le président de la République là
aussi avoué à demi-mot au lundi dans son
allocution et est-ce qu'il apporte et
bien des réponses à cette crise
démocratique on a eu des pistes en tout
cas sur sa réponse dans son interview au
journaux du groupe Ebra c'était hier
matin mais Macron qui évoque dans cette
interview le fait que les citoyens
veulent être plus associés aux décisions
ce sont ces mots alors il revendiquent
d'avoir essayé d'associer ces citoyens
j'ai fait le grand débat la convention
citoyenne sur le climat celle sur la fin
de vie dit-il puis dans sa réponse il
s'empresse de fustiger les extrêmes ce
qui remettent en cause la légitimité les
institutions et enfin il lâche cette
phrase le référendum d'initiative
partagée est une très bonne chose ça
tombe bien d'ailleurs Alex puisque le
Conseil constitutionnel pourrait envahir
des uns ça serait on le saura le 3 mars
le 3 mai prochain et alors Benjamin et
dubitatif sur l'avenir de se faire
d'omnitive partagée on en parlera et en
tout cas dans cette interview Quentin et
bien président et aussi interrogé sur le
référendum tout court voilà on vient de
le voir effectivement à l'écran c'est
Nathalie Morel la journaliste du groupe
Ebra qu'on connaît bien ici à Public
Sénat qui lui pose la question tout
simple et le référendum il répond là
aussi cette phrase le référendum est un
outil et j'aurais à m'en saisir pour des
sujets que je choisirais le sujet
effectivement été évoqué visiblement
avec les chefs de fil de la majorité qui
était reçu lundi à l'Elysée c'est ce que
vous a dit hier François Patriat Alex
c'était sur ce plateau écoutez le chef
de fil du groupe LRM au Sénat
il fallait il fallait utiliser un
fantôme redonner la parole au peuple
mais pas sur une question êtes-vous pour
ou contre de vendre plus de retraite
parce que si on connaît la réponse avant
ça c'est facile le sujet de la loi alors
moi j'ai proposé on pourrait faire un
référendum sur la fin de vie je pense
que c'est un sujet sur lequel on peut
interroger les Français c'est un sujet
de société profond et là on n'est pas
difficile
on est passé
il y aura une proposition
issue du débat qui a eu
dans la convention citoyenne et des
propositions qui sont faites qui peuvent
déboucher sur un modèle français ce sera
un modèle français d'aide à la fin de
vie ça me paraît être un sujet sur
lequel on peut interroger les Français
un modèle français sur la fin de vie on
se dit que c'est pas une prise de risque
politique très forte même si ce sujet
touche à l'intime pour Emmanuel Macron
cela permettrait d'apaiser les français
pour style peut-être lundi dans son
allocution il avait dit que les citoyens
avaient je cite le sentiment persistant
que voter ne serait plus décidé merci
beaucoup quent on va parler des
solutions notamment du référendum mais
un obéiti d'abord un mot sur le constat
est-ce que selon vous on vit une crise
démocratique et une désaffection des
Français vis-à-vis de notre cinquième
république oui on vit une crise
démocratique mais Emmanuel Macron n'en
est pas le seul responsable il en est
d'ailleurs presque j'allais dire un des
symptômes d'une certaine manière et son
accession au pouvoir aussi et le produit
d'une crise démocratique qui vient de
très loin en l'occurrence mais qui s'est
accéléré finalement depuis peut-être
2007 depuis le changement de génération
de de président de la République je
crois que ça c'est une un élément
important qu'il faut avoir en tête si
vous voulez quand même dans une
démocratie la légitimité procède du
peuple le problème si vous voulez c'est
imposer ce sentiment cette idée cette
sensation je sais pas comment il faut
l'appeler en tout cas cette perception
que non seulement le peuple n'avait plus
confiance dans ses dirigeants toutes les
études d'opinion depuis un certain
nombre d'années le démontre mais ce qui
est plus grave en démocratie c'est que
et c'est ce qui est une perception en
tout cas vraisemment de nombreux
segments de l'opinion publique c'est que
il considère que les élus les élites
dirigeantes non plus confiance dans le
peuple et ça c'est beaucoup plus
problématique dans une démocratie
c'est-à-dire que le sentiment qui se
diffracte c'est l'idée qu'il y aurait
une forme de Sécession des dirigeants
gouverner d'Emmanuel Macron qui aggrave
actuellement cette crise démocratique
c'est multifactoriel d'abord il y a
quelque chose de général vous regardez
de la Pologne aux États-Unis de la Suède
au Portugal aujourd'hui vous avez pas
une démocratie occidentale qui va bien
même les pays scandinaves qu'on disait
idéal etc aujourd'hui sont en crise
c'est lié à plusieurs facteurs des
structurations de l'espèce public font
de la classe moyenne la démocratie est
fondée sur le classement moyen
importante quand vous avez un écart
entre les revenus qui augmentent
forcément vous avez une fragilisation de
l'autre côté vous avez en effet un
question institutionnelle en France
notre Constitution est quand même une
certaine façon a d'ailleurs que la
Constitution mes pensées mode de scrutin
etc et quand même pensé pour une époque
avec une structuration de l'espace
politique et de l'espace partisan qui
n'est plus la nôtre aujourd'hui et donc
ce faisant il y a des fragilisations et
un sentiment de manque de
représentativité et de manque de
représentation au sens large parce que
dans la représentation il y a également
l'efficacité de l'action publique quand
vous avez une dilution de responsabilité
internationale nationale etc il y a une
fragilisation ce que vivent également
nos voisins et ensuite en effet il y a
une pratique du pouvoir qui peut être
celle d'Emmanuel Macron mais qui est
sont générale je dirais un état
aujourd'hui de la classe politique qui
apparaît comme étant en opposition avec
ce que peuvent attendre les Français
donc tout ça fait que en effet on est
dans une crise démocratique que cette
crise démocratique elle est profonde et
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'en a pas à lui seul
les clés le problème c'est que en promo
en promettant un référendum tous les ans
parce que là en effet on a le droit
Optimo alors sur le référendum sur la
fin de vie je doute de la consumérité
mais bon a priori c'est comme lors des
élections présidentielles on avait le
droit à l'immigration etc tout ça ne
rentre en règle générale pas dans le
cadre de l'article 11 et bon là je suis
technicien en faisant ça mais de l'autre
côté vous avez eu quasiment le un
référendum annoncé par an il devait y
avoir un référendum à choix multiple un
moment ça aussi c'était pas
constitutionnel un référendum sur
l'environnement là il va il fallait la
valve du Sénat évidemment ça n'allait
pas passer donc aujourd'hui la promesse
de référendum est un peu une tarte à la
crème enfin et bien vous avez une
réforme de la Constitution qu'on
pourrait envisager pour un RIP etc mais
le climat n'a jamais été aussi
défavorable on a une chambre qui est
d'une couleur politique le Sénat
l'Assemblée qui est d'une la couleur
politique déjà en règle générale ça fait
que vos réformes consciennes ne passent
pas qui plus est vous avez une Assemblée
nationale exposée façon puzzle vous avez
un gouvernement qui ne tient pas sa
majorité et qui d'ailleurs elle-même est
relative donc depuis 1962 on n'a jamais
eu de climat aussi défavorable pour
réviser une constitution en lançant un
grand chantier sur les institutions
Emmanuel Macron là encore cherche à
noyer le poisson il sait très bien il
est pas fou qu'il y aura pas de révision
consoles sous ce quinquennat et donc ce
faisant il participe à creuser la crise
démocratique parce qu'il va susciter de
l'espoir mais cet espoir là je crains
malheureusement que même s'il est
nécessaire ils finissent déçu en tout
cas Emmanuel Macron il parle de
référendum sur des sujets de son choix
il parle également de davantage de
conventions citoyenne sur le modèle de
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie est-ce que pour vous ça peut
résoudre le problème un objectif écoutez
la convention citoyenne je ne crois pas
si vous voulez la démocratie elle est
parlementaires elle est direct ou à les
sociales le problème c'est que la
démocratie parlementaire aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron a quand même une
difficulté avec cette démocratie
parlementaire on l'a vu lors de la
démocratie directe on a du mal à croire
que il va aller au référendum dans les
semaines ou dans les mois qui viennent
et la démocratie sociale ceux qui en
parle le mieux c'est sont les quand même
les syndicats donc je ne suis pas sûr
mais si vous voulez le problème
aujourd'hui d'Emmanuel Macron c'est quoi
c'est que il essaie de gagner du temps
il essaie de gagner du temps en espérant
que les taux à un moment donné se
desserre pour essayer d'élargir sa base
majoritaire à l'assemblée et nationale
d'ailleurs on en parle plus du tout mais
je rappelle qu'il y a un mois il confie
une mission à sa première ministre
d'essayer d'élargir cette base
parlementaire je ne sais pas où on en
est aujourd'hui de ce de ce chantier là
alors dans les rencontres
Hervé Marseille le chef de fil des
centristes qui pouvait être peut-être
quelqu'un qui aurait pu un moment
prendre une main tendue sur des textes
etc nous a raconté que lors des
rencontres à Matignon puisqu'il était à
Matignon un chef de fil de l'UDI aussi
la première liste n'a même pas évoqué le
sujet d'élargir cette cette majorité
comme si elle savait que c'était
complètement pliée d'avance Benjamin
Morel c'est peine perdu finalement de
redonner de la capacité de gouvernement
en élargissant et en ralliant la droite
mais le problème n'est pas aujourd'hui
d'élargir la majorité c'est de sauver la
majorité relative enfin il y a quasiment
plus d'Inter groupes ensemble vous avez
des groupes politiques qui se tirent
dessus quasiment à balle réel à
l'Assemblée nationale au sein même de la
majorité donc la question c'est de tenir
l'attelage horizon modem et Renaissance
avec les différentes tendances de
Renaissance on en est pas élargissement
de la majorité et élargir avec qui avec
elle c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire
sur la réforme des retraites en disant
on passe de 65 à 64 ans dès le mois de
janvier pour toper avec LR on a vu le
résultat ça donne à 49,3 et une notion
de censure qui échoue à nevoit près donc
il y a pas de partenaires potentiel pour
la majorité et il y a personne qui a
tout à fait intérêt à monter dans le
navire à ce stade là donc on a un
gouvernement qui tient comme il peut et
il y a quand même un fait révélateur
vous savez en 2008 on a créé une méthode
de contrôle des nominations du président
de la République ça n'intéresse que les
conditionnalistes mais on a fait quand
même à l'époque une disposition qui
devait faire que même si le président
avait un contrôle sur ces nominations ça
n'allait jamais être enclenché qu'un
système de majoritaire remboursé par les
deux commissions bref c'est complexe
c'est fait pour pas marcher bah ça a
marché le président de l'ADEME qui
pourtant était pas excessivement
radioactif pour les députés et qui avait
déjà été nommé quelques mois auparavant
a été a vu sa candidature au toquée et
donc là on a quand même quelque chose
qu'on ne pensait pas avoir une réunion
le maire Charleville-Mézières qui avait
rallier Emmanuel Macron dans la prise on
a quelque chose qu'on ne pensait pas
voir arriver et qui est arrivé et sans
dit beaucoup beaucoup sur l'état des
majorités au Parlement mais si on va
finir ce club des territoires en parlant
de la reconstruction de Notre-Dame de
Paris puisque et bien demain cela fera 4
ans jour pour jour que Notre Dame a
brûlé et depuis et bien 130 entreprises
travaillent à la reconstruction de Lady
de l'édifice et nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de l'une d'entre elles une
entreprise qui a restaure les vitraux de
la cathédrale de Notre-Dame de Paris
dans un atelier en Île-de-France un
reportage de Cécile sixo
un nettoyage minutieux et ma grotte et
mettre verrier sous sa lame un vitrail
de Notre-Dame datant du 19e siècle moi
je suis restauratrice de vitraux depuis
2013 on intervient principalement pour
les monuments historiques et les musées
partout en France et donc on a des des
compétences un peu spécifiques sur des
restaurations complexes
grâce à son savoir-faire elle a été
réquisitionnée juste après l'incendie de
Notre-Dame en avril 2019 pour sortir les
vitraux de la cathédrale et les mettre à
l'abri c'était pas fumant mais c'était
encore très encombré il y avait
énormément de décombres et on laisse pas
de trois semaines à peu près on a sorti
l'ensemble des baies hautes de l'édifice
sans savoir tellement l'État le la
stabilité de l'édifice etc à ce moment
là on
ignorait encore tout deux ans plus tard
elle a été choisie avec huit artisans
pour restaurer quatre verrières peu
endommager par l'incendie mais
extrêmement poussiéreuse elles sont
nettoyées centimètres par centimètre il
y a eu beaucoup de poussière liées à
l'incendie
ne poussèrent très noir qu'on qui sont
accumulés en surface des vitraux mais en
fait initialement il y avait déjà
beaucoup de poussière qui était aussi en
place par par le temps en fait ils ont
pas été déposés ces vitraux là depuis
qu'ils ont été installés au milieu du
XIXe siècle
des études de projet et puis il y a eu
tous les appels d'offres qui ont permis
d'attribuer ces contrats depuis près de
1000 artisans travaillent à la
rénovation dont 500 directement sur le
site et pour le moment les délais sont
tenus tout comme le budget au total pour
la rénovation plus de 700 millions
d'euros ont été récoltés grâce à des
dons
ont donné au-delà de 700 millions
d'euros on aura même de quoi poursuivre
des restaurations sur des parties
extérieures de la cathédrale qui était
déjà bien dégradé avant l'incendie et
qui méritait des travaux de restauration
Notre-Dame sera plus belle que jamais
pour accueillir les futurs visiteurs ils
sont attendus nombreux près de 15
millions par an
voilà pour ce reportage de Cécile Sixou
sur la reconstruction de Notre-Dame de
Paris on va finir ce club des
territoires et bien en regardant ce
qu'il y a dans nos quotidiens régionaux
avec vos Quentin
[Musique]
et quand on commence avec le Midi Libre
et l'interview du président de la
République voilà on l'avait vu notamment
avec son déplacement en Alsace dans le
Bas-Rhin quand le président de la
République se déplace dans un
département il accorde une interview au
journal local et c'est donc le Midi
Libre et qui a interrogé le président de
la République et hier et ils ont posé
des questions sur la réforme des
retraites d'ailleurs ils sont allés tous
de gauche dans la question vous ne la
retirez vous ne la retirez jamais il a
répondu je viens de la promulguer et de
redire qu'il a fait ce qu'il avait dit
pendant la campagne présidentielle et il
a continué ensuite c'est ça la
démocratie c'est d'avoir l'honnêteté de
dire quand on va chercher la confiance
des Français voilà ce que je vais faire
et puis hier pendant sa visite dans
l'Hérault et bien chef de l'État a fait
des annonces en faveur des enseignants
et ça fait également la Une des journées
régionaux ce matin voilà il y a beaucoup
de titres qui reviennent sur ces
annonces pour les enseignants aux quatre
coins du pays vous le voyez le Dauphiné
Libéré à Grenoble qui parle de 3
milliards pour les profs le gouvernement
ne veut pas d'enseignant à moins de 2000
euros par mois Ouest-France revient
également sur CEO entre 100 et 130 euros
net par mois pour tous les profs à
partir de septembre avec une part fixe
et une en fonction d'autres missions on
continue avec le travailler plus pour
gagner plus que résumé ainsi par le
Républicain Lorrain à Metz et enfin le
Télégramme en Bretagne à Brest qui
revient également sur ce coup de pouce
au enseignants et puis Quentin pour
terminer à la Une de La Dépêche du Midi
et bien sûr brûlant a surveillé ce
weekend ouais c'est au tour de
l'autoroute a69 c'est voila que tout
oppose le journal raconte comment et
bien depuis 30 ans il y a un conflit qui
se joue autour d'un projet de nouvelle
autoroute entre Toulouse et le sud du
Tarn on va suivre ça de très près car il
pourrait y avoir et bien des
manifestations et des débordements c'est
ce qui crie ce matin à La Dépêche
d'ailleurs et bien nos reporters seront
sur place ce week-end on en reparlera
dans cette émission bien sûr merci
beaucoup Quentin merci messieurs d'avoir
participé à ce club des territoires
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une très
bonne journée sur Public Sénat et un
très bon weekend
[Musique]